what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today is day two
of carnival yesterday i was not ready
that was my first festival oh my gosh
that was that was crazy but today um
we're going to be asking a variety of
questions to the people on the streets
here we're going to ask girls rate
themselves one to ten see what they say
ten always always
we're gonna we're gonna also be asking
different questions about andrew tate
and other hot topics right now uh we're
gonna be here so long i just figured
let's do a lot before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that notification bell like the video
i'm so tired of you all a like is free i
like it's where you don't have to pay
for it you don't have to deal with
notifications just like it leave a
comment let me know what questions we
should ask next time
[Music]
have you have you ever accepted the bare
minimum from a guy
sadly i have have you ever heard the
phrase accepting the bare minimum no yes
i have have you ever heard a woman say
they've accepted the bare minimum it
depends on what kind of woman i'm
speaking to normally i'll choose the you
know sophisticated type so i don't get
that issue but um yeah sometimes what is
the bare minimum the bare minimum
is not the bare minimum because women's
a diamond you never put a price on a
woman in it you get me you have to treat
them with their respect and give them
their value when they're worth in it i
feel like the bare minimum is a good
morning text a good night text seeing
how you are speaking to me fruited like
throughout the day just stuff like that
even planning dates is the bare minimum
no bare minimum a lame ass man that's
got nothing in his life and just feeds
off you
hallelujah praise the lord
the bare minimum is like when a guy's
not doing enough he's only doing he's
only doing what he feels is what so what
is enough specific so enough might be
different from men but females it might
not be the same thing like if you get a
good guy he's gonna know what a female
wants so the bare minimum it just
depends on what kind of guy you're
looking for in it but with me i'm a very
nice guy so i might give him more than a
bare minimum what do you think is the
bare minimum from a girl
[Music]
offering to pay by accepting that you're
not going to pay and
doing what you need to do
to pleasure your partner so sex and
offering to pay is the bare minimum the
bare minimum yeah back rubs in it back
up back that's it reciprocate what
reciprocate energy like the bare minimum
i would do for you do for me no yeah
it's the same like you just got to
reciprocate my energy if you ain't
reciprocating them what's what's the
point screaming about equality nowadays
yeah treat me exactly the same way you
want me to treat you no i think the bare
minimum of the expect from women is at
least be caring i think those are kind
of our nature caring
attentive i think those kind of things
it's abandonment for us yeah the same
thing good morning text good night text
planning dates just making time for your
significant other or the guy yeah feel
like men and women's standards are equal
yeah who do you think has higher
standards men are women women have high
standards for men than men i think men
not me percy but we're [ __ ] here
therefore anything like that getting
[ __ ] getting [ __ ] but girls some
girls are like that as well but they
will have more of a higher sign alert
even relationship wise girl they want a
guy with money and he looks good this
and that
sometimes the man just wants comfort so
you know business so yeah i mean i'm i'm
the same like to get it like some girls
they
they set unrealistic targets like but at
the end of the day if i'm giving you
my all you have to give me you're all
back hundred percent they're burning
before girl not giving me enough
attention talking to numerous guys at
once
and just acting like a fool but you know
i don't go for that type of woman i like
me on a nice girl who knows where she's
going in life and yeah man
yeah the same thing good morning text
good night texts planning dates just
making time for your significant other
or the guy yeah i do that what is the
bare minimum from a woman
i think hygiene's the most important
thing most important thing and the next
thing would be communication and not to
look at my phone what about what about
like cooking cleaning is that is that
should that be required in a
relationship we're living in a 21st
century man should be able to cook for
themselves and i wouldn't expect a woman
to cook all the time
but because of how society's been set up
unless i'm going to be a maternity i'll
cook if you're a maternity someone has
to cook when she just does nothing
doesn't cook doesn't clean just sits
there and expects expenses when you
expect when you expect when he works
do you think you know how girls do i say
i'm a queen i deserve to be treated like
a queen can men say i deserve to be
treated like a kid 100 percent oh yeah
if you're if you're a good dad
you're doing it yeah you work all day
you work your ass off like not going to
the pub but if you work your ass off all
day i'll have your food on the table
i'll have your clothes cleaned
i'll have it all ready for you i don't
know
not ironing no i don't iron clothes
no
no dryer
dryer tumble dryer okay you guys have
tumbled tires here
if you're getting food because i'm a big
eater she has your [ __ ] ready okay that
was no ironing though that's too far
that's too far do we always hear women
talk about how they should be treated
like queens but we never hear men talk
about how they should be treated like a
king because i think it goes back to the
days of men being in charge it's a man's
world but i feel like now it's time for
women to be appreciated as you know the
women won the world uh the euros so it
shows that women have progressed so far
so yeah they should be three like queens
they should were you offering the same
things you were expecting from him
well i believe in princess treatments so
maybe not exactly
but
yeah not exactly men should require king
treatment
i mean yeah
because what will equal say yeah i guess
yeah
no it's just it's a common complaint i
hear from guys it's like girls want
princess they want to be treated like
queens but they're like why don't we get
to be treated like kings do you feel
like that's a valid point no it is very
valid so if you had a brother what do
you think he should require from a girl
it's something i think as girls we don't
think about it from their point of view
a lot 100
okay i have a very biased opinion
because i feel like the guy should be
like the financial leads okay but then
again for my like if my brother was with
a girl i would also want her to like
financially help him too
so it's hard it is hard do you think if
a guy is paying for everything he's
entitled to sex whenever he wants
not exactly but he is entitled to other
things what do you mean like just effort
like the girl should be playing a lot
putting in a lot of effort if the guy's
asked if the guy's paying for everything
and giving her everything he she wants
so what do you what do you look at as
effort because a common complaint this
is just from the boys this is what they
tell me they say girls say they put in
effort but there's no like tangible
thing they can say that they do so like
is that cooking every meal for him
cleaning for him like what does he get
in return for paying all the bills i
feel like cooking wait are we talking
about marriage or relationship because i
feel like cooking is more wife duties
and a guy should expect that when he's
married to the girl not when they're in
a relationship but in a relationship i
should expect a goal if he's paid if
he's financially helping her out to give
her like good morning texts good morning
calls good night what text ask him how
he's doing be like his shoulder to lean
on to be there yeah would you say that
him spending money on you is husband
duties and not boyfriend duties
yes and no because it depends on how
much he's spending on you and what he's
buying for you and what he's paying for
so would you say it's fair to say he
should expect you to cook and clean some
of the time
if he's gonna spend money on you some
other time
i think we just don't always think about
it from their point of view you know
what i mean yeah that is a very valid
point i think i agree with that you know
oh my gosh
i'm never fooled by it like that so yeah
what you're saying is funny
who do you think accepts the bare
minimum more men or women
women women because they care when they
are in it like
guys some guys are just giving out the
bare minimum everyday women women i
think women i think we accept because
there's a lot of women out here that
will say this and that but they ain't
got much going on for them they like a
girl say to you oh you need to drive
while she's on the bus huh how does that
work do all women deserve respect
most women deserve their respect not all
women
because some women
know their value they come they they
have principles about themselves they
have loyal it's just you know it
entangles from stem from the parent you
think of a woman sleeping around she
deserves to be courted and taken out on
nice dates
no have you have you heard the phrase
the bare minimum many times what is the
bare minimum for a woman i don't think
there's a minimum i think everyone
should play the part so if if i'm dating
a woman i don't expect her to to come
and say oh i'm gonna pay for dinner or
whatever but if she invite me to dinner
i expect her to pay what do you guys
think of andrew tate oh
he's a [ __ ]
andrew t
you know what what he's a bad guy but
he's not as bad as it seems like oh i
don't like him i really don't like him
he's not a bit of me do you do you agree
with him getting banned yeah i 100
degree um yeah i'm fully healed for it i
hate him he is a smelly snail would you
say it's because he's misogynistic i
think he's sexist he's homophobic he's
all the above and he shouldn't be able
to have the platform that he has what do
you think about do you think that the
women that say that men ate [ __ ] and men
are trash should they be banned too
because i like i think that's sexist
well say men attract yeah like the girls
that say like money and [ __ ] men are
trash yeah but men are
they are
even though i'm a guy who's by myself
but the med system is trash women are
trash too like i know some trash-ass
women that are that are not good to men
so it's like i feel like obviously
everyone is trash but men are worse
and that's it thank you so much andrew t
i can't lie here and you chase a man
brother i ain't gonna lie yeah
i i don't agree with everything he says
but i no i do i feel like he's doing it
for clout and banter you know on
internet chat a lot of [ __ ] you get
popular that's what i don't think he
really believes in all of that because
he's talking a lot
do you not feel like he's spitting real
facts a few bits here that i'm like you
know what man can understand it but a
lot of like one what did he say was he
said yeah no men and women are not equal
we're not the same i was like you can't
really be saying that nowadays men and
women aren't the same oh
he was talking about like like a man
cheating on a woman and a woman cheating
on a man he's like we're not the same
it's different do you know what's up
with me you know the ferrari um example
he gave he was just like oh if a girl
sorry if a guy keeps trying to break
into my ferrari i'm gonna move it
something like that citing along the
lines of that like would you if you if
you have a goal would you let her keep
getting moved to or would you not
so would you let your girl get moved to
continuously or would you move it would
i move it no would you stop your girl
yeah
you want to keep it in the same place
why do you not like andrew tate he's i
don't ever can swear but he's to see you
next tuesday he has no morals
he he's he yeah he's i don't even have
any work he is a absolute villain broth
absolute felon um i'm better than andrew
tate so i can't complain
i just think he's rude there's no need
for is there because he's a cun
you think he's sexist he's very
misogynistic
exactly what i was going to say
yeah so would you guys agree with him
getting banned no i don't think so i
think he's bringing positive energy like
you know the [ __ ] vibe right andrew
tape bob if you can hear me you're the
man brother i can't lie keep doing your
thing in it he's just chilling like he's
made money he's doing well for himself
you know what i mean i don't think it's
fair
like no no no the last [ __ ] he said is
kind of [ __ ] up
why is he [ __ ] okay okay okay maybe
not [ __ ] up but a lot of people might
take a fence away says but then again
you've got [ __ ] racist people online
that ain't banned but
the fact is the fact is if he wasn't
saying something that was real and true
why would he get banned
okay so i have a question i have a
question do you agree with him being
banned on all platforms do you think yes
no no i don't agree i don't agree i
think
i think he should be able to voice his
opinion and then let people know that
there's people like him in the world and
who to avoid i don't think he should be
banned on everything
do you think he should be able to do i
think he should be able to talk but i do
think he should be able to like be
restricted to what he says and i think
people should be able to see
like what what it's about and there's
people out there like that then should
all of the women that say men ain't [ __ ]
and men are trash should they all be
banned too because that's
so different it's so different it's not
different it's exactly the same but
is to an extreme his opinion is not that
women are trash whose opinion is that
women shouldn't drive women shouldn't go
to work women are just there for sex
it's competing
they share your profit
because they're their proper their
property what do you mean why not camera
man
so andrew tate once said right
that if a man goes out and has sex with
someone else if he has a girlfriend
it's exercise
but if a girl goes out and has sex with
a man
is cheating
and that is
so go ahead so
these are contradicting themselves
because they're doing the same thing as
him they're doing the same thing as him
but then get mad when he does the same
thing back so they want to play one role
but when someone else gets banned he's
like it's called a minute he's he's a
prick but
he's an acceptable prick so he needs to
be wary of the things he says like i
don't agree with most of his comments
but sometimes he does make a valid point
so girls need to understand that if
they're gonna you know get mad at him
they need to think about what they say
as well enough but wouldn't you say that
saying a whole gender is trash and ain't
[ __ ] and why don't you let me let me let
me finish let me finish what did you say
that's miss andristic so like wouldn't
you say that is open sexism against men
no no no he is
[Music]
i think no one everyone should be
allowed to voice their own opinion
facts but what they're allowed to say
should be like
on a level you know just so we were
aware of them sort of people in the
world
so we don't try
and they're not trusting what is this
mom
trash
guys guys
guys guys guys guys so i'm saying i'm
saying like should it shouldn't the
women be banned that are saying men
ain't [ __ ] because is it i think that's
worse to say a whole gender isn't [ __ ]
oh wait let me finish i would i think
it's worse to say a whole i wouldn't
wait let me finish let me finish i think
it's worse to say a whole gender isn't
[ __ ] and it's trash i think that's worse
than saying oh
agree with you however
with the things that women have been
through are very different to what men
have been through so women have to fight
for rights men were handed right
men were entitled to [ __ ] whoever
they want men were entitled still now
religions allow you to marry five people
women women can't marry five men
so okay okay okay okay so so that this
is
is the thing this is the thing that's a
common perception but women we didn't
have to fight in wars historically
men died to build society up so it's
like so situation
everyone should be cheating
and this whole situation
freedom of [ __ ] speech if you want to
say something say it obviously don't
offend people we'll try not to and
that's that i agree with you i think if
you have [ __ ] opinions you should be
able to put them on a platform yeah
and i think if you're gonna abuse people
online and stuff like that you probably
shouldn't be allowed it but if you're
not and you're just wishing your opinion
in your own way i don't see why not it
just warns other people that there's
people like that in the world yeah i
agree with you i agree why do women only
complain about double standards when
they don't benefit them rob [ __ ] the
double standards team rav if my girl's
moving loose yeah she can [ __ ] right off
do you know what i mean like my wife a
year she's gotta be [ __ ] 100 with all
that you know i mean so question for the
girls why do you guys only care about
double standards when they benefit you
so no because this is a perfect example
right because if he's
right first of all second of all who is
andrew t
who even is that bro like who is he to
talk about females like that he's no one
he he's no one he's worth number three
he's just because he's got money doesn't
mean he's that guy okay simple respect
respecting women having mandate okay you
guys are you guys are diverting from the
question though because i asked you i
asked you i asked you like like no no no
no no no this is the point this is the
point you're diverting from the question
because he's saying something that's men
ain't [ __ ] men are trash like you're
you're categorizing a home
the question i asked you was
why shouldn't the female tick talkers
that say men and [ __ ] and men are trash
be banned too because we can
because we haven't
they don't have a point to prove yeah
they're just saying things that benefit
them yeah and when it doesn't benefit
them they start moving all angry and
that and start yeah they don't know why
now they don't even know what to say
they're walking away now but i thank you
for the lovely interview it's been
actually yummy check my socials
so this is the thing this is the thing
you'll you'll see this
time and time again whenever you do the
equivalent
it's like girls have never in their life
thought about things from a man's point
of view it's always from us because the
whole our whole society
our whole society is catered towards
women what do you guys think of andrew
tate no i'm not a fan i'm not a fan do
you think he should have been banned no
he shouldn't have been banned well
social media is there for freedom of
speech so would you rather struggle
paycheck to paycheck but the guy's
faithful he'll love you forever or all
your bills are paid forever but he
cheats um the first option the first
option
the first option
why
because honesty and integrity is very
important yeah i prefer not to be like
cheater or like that people is not
trustful
yeah feelings matter more than financial
security would you rather date a girl
that has 50 bodies or
50 dollars worth of credit card debt you
have to wife one fifty thousand credit
card debt eat all [ __ ] day rob yeah i
mean man like me i'm a buller like that
you know what i mean plus andrew tape
but he probably sent me them fifty bags
buff just for seeing this interview like
you know what i mean my man's a g like
that
don't disrespect my man in it
love love andrew tate yeah next question
would you guys rather take a guy that
you struggle paycheck to paycheck but
he's faithful or would you rather have a
guy that pays 100 of the bills but he
steps out from time to time
faithful we go 50 50. because i've got
my own money so i'll pay for myself you
pay for yourself
one or two no would you would you rather
let's go now no fightful
faithful
she has your [ __ ] ready okay that was no
ironing though that's too far that's too
far would you guys rather have a guy
that you struggle paycheck to paycheck
okay for the rest of your life but he
doesn't cheat on you or a guy he you get
to have a luxurious lifestyle for life
taken care of care but he cheats
paycheck for sure
she is rich rich i'm all for it um
it depends who you're cheating with it's
just it's just no emotions just
no no no it's like
no no so it would just be like escorts
like that type of thing like like no one
he has feelings for you're the only one
he loves i take the paycheck i've lived
through a man who pays for everything
and there's still trash yeah or what a
rich player already
would you rather take a girl that has 50
bodies
or 50 000 in credit card debt you have
to help pay off i would call 50 buddies
but we're gonna have to go to the clinic
together we're gonna have to go to the
clinic together rate yourself one to ten
i don't need to rate myself one to ten i
let the garden choose that but i know
i'm a ten anyway so
eight because i'm cute i'm nice i'm
loyal smart me one to ten
i would say i'm a solid 10. would you
say when we say 10 that means we're
perfect
okay say you're perfect okay no maybe
i'll change that to a nap because i know
i'm not perfect and i have things to
work on
but i feel like the man that wants like
i'm perfect for any man that wants to be
with me do you feel like a man's perfect
for you because don't we all have stuff
like we're all human right so we all
have stuff we gotta like improve on so i
don't think i'm perfect for any guy
because like i have [ __ ] that's wrong
with me just like everyone else rate
yourselves one to ten ten ten ten ten
twenty ten rate yourselves one to ten
eleven out of ten eleven one
one
why why did you give why did you give
yourself a one because i'm neo
would you say that means you're perfect
yeah in every way
who wants to improve more men are women
i feel like both genders should improve
who who tries that self-improvement more
men or women women definitely
i would say men
because i like you know with gym stuff
physical stuff
but emotional stuff i would say women
women like there's just so much pressure
on us
in from society
how are you trying to improve more for
if like because you're not the first
girl that said this i've been asking
this all day what do you rate yourself
one to ten ten ten ten doesn't that mean
you're perfect yeah and everywhere so
it's like so i'm saying but like like
how are we trying to improve if we think
we're perfect i mean not not perfect
percy but i think it's just one of those
things that you have to tell yourself
that i mean
that's what i get it's like a confidence
you have to say it till you believe it
but like you're still trying to improve
what did you say that's like just living
in delusion though
i like delusional sometimes yes you know
that's
that's what some people say so what are
your requirements like standards for a
girl oh beautiful beautiful so slender
as in beautiful face and body so that
means she have to be going to the gym if
she's not gonna do this oh well no ways
i don't want her no never why do you
think um in society we shame people that
are drug addicts and alcohol addicts but
not people that are overweight because
the people that is drug addicts i think
they need help because it's a mental
condition but um overweight is it is a
mental condition as well so you need a
balance so we we need to put more
emphasis on both actually who settles
more men or women i would probably say
men
are
awesome
why they make a lot of men and they're
certain by beauty which is important but
the other things they need to look for
which i don't think about and and then
later on i think it costs them further
down the line so i think all men uh men
are heterosexual yes are driven by
something beautiful but i think they
don't often think about women too but
i'm thinking about what else do i need
to sustain a wonderful relationship and
my god they regret it i think the
divorce rates show that well i think in
modern day society i think men are the
ones who sell it quicker because of the
modern restraints
that we have we don't have the same as
what we had say our our father's
generation our grandfather generation
they had totally something different but
what women have done their women are
still
they're modern but they want traditional
men so they weren't meant to be able to
pay all the bills and that was fine for
our fathers and grandfathers but what
women don't understand our fathers and
grandfathers got virgins yeah that's
true
men's sell quicker because you're not
getting what your fathers and
grandfathers well it's almost like um
today
uh women want traditional outcomes but
we don't offer the things that men want
anymore because we're not we're not
obvious the average age of first
marriage in the uk is 31. how many
bodies does a [ __ ] have by 31.
and the second thing is they don't have
purity anymore because 90 of your eggs
are gone by 30. so there's no fertility
either so it's like who's really getting
the bad deal in today's market i'd
probably have to say i mean i don't
believe that there's so there is good
quality men and women out there but i
think it's people have to realize that
there's certain mistakes you want to
avoid
so for example i want to say absence but
i think there's a lot of value in maybe
number one waiting until you get right
personally i think that's what i'm
talking about is you've got to have i
think dads at home in the first place to
educate boys and girls what the right
thing is to look for because otherwise
you just made a mistake by just saying
because the outer wrapping is beautiful
therefore what's inside isn't and that's
that can be an expensive lesson to learn
it's ready for girls all because they're
out of rapping that's gorgeous does not
mean what's inside is i think pretty
much
there is a safe job is in character same
the same the same thing what people want
like what we were talking before people
want that people will say well they want
eight nines and tens but do you know how
to actually rate eight nines or ten
that's absolutely fantastic i don't have
a problem with people wanting a nines
and ten but i always ask the question
what are you prepared number one to do
for the a nine to ten i know you
prepared to pay for it
and a lot of people don't want that they
want eight nine and ten to be the person
on deliver rules delivery they want
aegis alba to deliver a pizza
while making tracks
and djing for them for the prince and
princess so it's a bit it's
expectation that's what it is people
need to we need to manage expectations
and hypergamy of what women do have you
heard the term um
i i accepted the bare minimum
we were talking about this literally
several hours
one of my female friends said this to me
i literally why and you said well
because i never had a dad around and so
i don't know what to look for in a good
man and i think that there's millions of
women and and although that as well who
literally educated really well educated
over here did fantastic jobs over here
but over here there's train wreck on the
train and the guys they pick and
they'll settle for a major thing in
terms of universities you know talking
about his best careers but when it comes
to their guys we'll just get guys who
has eight two three shelf life if that i
think i think i think they know they
just don't care
that's my opinion i think i think i
think that's an excuse women use to get
sympathy from guys
to like be like oh i didn't have a dad i
didn't know but i'm sorry you all know
future in husband material and you all
are dating y'all are dating the futures
and say oh i'm shocked i'm shocked i
didn't he cheated
but but if you've never known if no
one's ever shown you how to pick it's
like
then the media then becomes your dad as
they said oh you've got to go for like
this guy good looking and rugged which
is fine but if whenever i never showed
you in terms of yes like i said i may be
out of packaging but you've got to look
for more into the character i i agree
but i feel like that's an excuse up to
like 22.
like i feel like after a certain age you
can kind of see the world
and say you know what i've seen these
guys and i've seen these guys what is
your ideal man my adult is someone who
actually cares about me
who doesn't you know just want one thing
and you know generally speaking as much
as
personality is very important i like
someone who's funny and all the generic
things but we can't look aside looks
you know i think it's also important to
have someone that you're attracted to
because i feel like it's quite selfish
if someone's good looking
but i mean someone's got a great
personality but you don't find them
attractive i think you're kind of
robbing them of someone who can give
them a full thing so i do think it's the
full package how how tall
oh
i'm gonna like six foot over
six foot out of place would be ideal how
how much money
listen somebody doesn't need to be
stable especially i think it's so
important when you date that you need to
be financially stable because
you know if you think about future plans
and things like that like roughly like
roughly how much do you have to make i
mean listen 40 40 40 000 pounds 30 000
pounds 20 thousand
he can pay for himself and also treat me
and i will do the same i want to be in
the position where i can do the same
reciprocation i mean so
yeah 50 50 at least what about what's
your ideal man ideal mom someone that's
family orientated definitely has their
own money
definitely tall
good morals definitely
why not i think
yeah on the spot
so what do you what do you guys offer
your ideal man what do we offer yes
listen i am the braz
so no i do that's what i said about
reciprocation i would want to do the
same i'm the kind of person that when i
do have a man 100 unlike babe i booked
us a flight to dubai i booked his flight
you're cooking you cleaning
are you cooking you clean it just
generic do i feel like that but who
should you do that themselves
yeah because in a household when we have
children you can say women should be
able to pay for dates like you could
eventually yeah
yeah i definitely think so but i do
think first date i think it's just nice
yeah you're interested exactly so i
don't i do think first date should
always work yeah if i'm honest
have you heard women say like i accepted
the bare minimum
and i have been a woman that accepted
the birmingham what is the bare minimum
things that you use
that guy should do like without you
having to ask like
his company to me because for example
i've been i've unfortunately why am i
out of myself like this but i've kind of
spoken to guys who we've never even went
on a date ever like i'm talking i'm not
saying dates require extra money but we
didn't even go out that is bare minimum
his company is not enough that's bare
minimum because my company is their
minimum i need to do more than that as
well so what do you guys think of andrew
tate it's one of those things where
people you know people want to gain
attention
and i feel like people do anything to
gain publicity and attention right now
so i think controversial opinions make
it more popular i think that's what i
think that's what he's kind of doing do
you think he should have been banned off
of all social media no freedom of speech
he's got his own opinion he says what he
says that's it it's up to you if you
want to partake or you don't yeah yeah i
don't think like his ideas should be
something that is um that is encouraged
between younger people but again we are
a country that you know we all believe
in freedom of speech and all of that so
should his rights to be able to share
what he thinks have been stopped i don't
think so but should his ideas on what
he's saying be shared with a bit more
information or like with people being
able to counter back giving more
information because i don't think the
answer to someone's controversy is by
shutting them up that doesn't stop
anything do you think it's because he's
misogynistic that they took him down
yeah i think i think so would you say by
that token that we should ban the women
that say men ain't [ __ ] and men are
trash because that's discriminating
against a whole group of men um i have
no idea i suppose if there's enough hype
about something then that's you know
there's power in in volume so if you
make a big enough scene about it he gets
removed it's just weird isn't it weird
how it's like only when they criticize
women but like when they criticize men
no one cares it's not that no one cares
i just think you gotta pick your battles
we know what we're fighting for we just
gotta continue doing what we're doing as
women personally you have to think of it
as um you can't be sexist towards men
because the
the way our what's accord the way the
world works is basically to benefit men
so it's like in my opinion if it doesn't
take the four eyes interpersonal
um
institutional i forgot the rest of the
two but if it's a thing where in general
men aren't i don't know man if men
aren't like in general men aren't
discriminated against so it wouldn't
really make sense to be like oh we
should ban the women in my opinion
andrew take kind of did what he did it
took a bit too far and the video that
came out of him a woman was like yeah
like he's got that was a sex play she
came out and said it was like a sex play
but so my question is like if men are
discriminated against why uh why do they
have higher suicide rates why do they
get three times the amount of sentencing
for the same crime why why are they why
are they often paid less for the same
job in different cities when you take in
the account like hours worked in the
industries they pay i think there isn't
there is an answer to the question
you're asking but i'm i'm currently like
i've forgotten the answer to it but of
course there's like what when when i
mean personally i do believe you can
discriminate against men and women
but i also believe that there are there
are different things impact um different
genders um a different amount like
women have been fighting for their
rights for decades and men have had
these rights why why are these things
and these are institutions and things
that were set up by men and to some
extent are still run by men so the pay
the pay gaps the paid the the pay for
these jobs who set the pay yeah the
people who are you know trying to
promote um help for people with mental
health issues and things like that who
are in charge of all these policies it's
still the men so if there is an issue
with what's going on with men and men
are still in positions of power why
aren't they also helping men and women
in the situation well a lot of our
societies actually run for women because
70 to 80 80 of consumer buying decisions
are made by women so so it's like our
whole media is tailored towards us
maybe our media might be tailored
towards women but again these are things
we're talking about positions of power
we're talking about things to do of
importance with laws with all these
these things are still controlled by men
so you know show the media is um tailors
to women and going to the shops you know
might be advertised more to cater to
women because that's their target
audience that's those are the people who
are might be using a service more but if
you're going to bring up things like oh
there's less people um the people who
like sorry what did you say something
about men um getting less pay in certain
certain jobs as well
that's something that's something that
i've said that's that's been set by men
so speak to the men and ask them why
they're setting those standards for
other men and instead of like asking
women why why should should we go ahead
and like well i'm saying shouldn't we be
fighting for equality all around yeah
that's like that's what that means
do you know what i'm saying like like
shouldn't we be fighting for men too
like it's not going to be fighting for
equity not equality
the thing is men or women in my opinion
are different by nature
and the needs that we want needs that
men want and the needs that women need
are totally different so rather than
fighting to be like men and compete with
men we should be fighting for an
environment that protects women and has
certain needs that tailors two women
let's say a man is working the same job
as a as a woman but that woman is a
mother of like let's say two children
but that man it doesn't have any
children of course you want them to be
paid the same however there needs to be
certain things like setting support in a
workplace to support that woman because
she has more people to look after that
money doesn't necessarily go only for
her the man because he doesn't have any
children or anyone to look after that
money goes for him his future whatever
but the woman has to share that with the
children and the household what goes for
her you know i'm trying to say
like that doesn't make sense because men
have kids too
i'm saying i'm never saying men can't
have kids i said for example let's say
the man didn't have children and the
woman did we want obviously equal pay
however there needs to be certain things
in place in the workplace to support the
woman who has children it may not be
free money but it could be through i
don't know discounts on certain things
because she has that money doesn't go to
her only it goes through the children so
she actually doesn't enjoy much of the
income she makes because she has to make
sacrifices for her family you know i'm
trying to say what did you say though
like we should just pay people based on
the job they do for example like if i
have a cameraman that that's a mom and a
cameraman that's not a mom i'm going to
pay them based on how good they do the
job so if the mom does a better job i'll
pay her more like i'm not going to think
about do you have children when i'm
hiring okay here's what i'm trying to
say is obviously if you want to employ
someone you're going to ask if they're
single have married you know based on no
because you need to know these kind of
things not for me because i hire like
six seven people what i'm trying to say
is
if if one person does one job and then
you're saying a person with a camera
a man or a woman or what did you say
okay so so i i paid him to come with me
today right i have to hire a cameraman
every time i go out and if i pay people
based on the job they do
so i'm not gonna think oh is she a mom
is she not a mom i'm just gonna pay
people based on the job i think that's
fair and so like i'm saying what i think
it's unfair when you give women special
treatment just because they're women
because men have kids too
so so like for example when you said you
said you should pay people and take into
account if they have kids or not and i'm
saying like no i think we should pay
people based on the job
no no no no no no no no
well let me answer this look at that
so what other special treatment do women
receive oh we got a ton like quotas like
there's specific quotas in companies
that say
often no because women don't want to do
hard jobs like for example
okay then what brick layers why is it 99
female plumbing why is it brick layers
why is it 99
female oil rigs like construction
male male sorry sorry sorry you
understand yeah right what other what
other areas and things do do we as women
receive preference have women
engineering they like i worked at i
worked in a sales company they hired me
on the spot because i was a woman i
don't think i should get special
treatment just because i'm a woman are
you sure it's not okay or do you have
you know right now not seeing yourself
as a
because i feel sometimes we feel when we
are in certain positions that we are
hired or accepted into things because of
our or sometimes race and sometimes our
gender and things like that but like
like you said these companies are like
companies they are not hiring based on
gender they are hiring based on skilled
employees if someone applies to their
role and and and what they want is
someone who can do the work properly
they will hire them and that's why they
still do not meet their quotas because
they're hiring the best employee and not
the best female employee or the best
male employee so sometimes you might
feel in some situations that you're
being hired because you're a woman but
that might not necessarily be the case
you may be hired because you have the
skills and the experience and the things
that is necessary for the job however
when you when when you say that all we
as women we shouldn't receive special
treatment what special treatment are we
receiving that's what i'm saying i'm
saying so okay yeah so can i can i can i
just like i just add this part so i'm
saying where i did you're just going on
for a while so i'm just gonna because
you had a lot of points so i just wanna
i i'm saying we shouldn't have quotas
there shouldn't be special treatment you
have a lot when you when you have a law
that says you need a certain amount of
women in a company i think that's wrong
because i i think it should be based on
your skills not your gender
and i entirely agree with you on that
that we shouldn't have these quotas but
these quotas are set in place to try and
increase the equality because there is
none at the moment and when we have
reached a position where we can achieve
this these quotas can and will be
removed because it's now it's a natural
thing to see people and of equal like do
we have quotas for races so so what what
what what is what does i i don't you i
need to do one at a time what is
equality what like what would equality
look like because some industries women
don't want to do so i don't think we can
have quote after quota for women to go
into construction i don't want to go in
construction most women i know don't
want to be in construction so i'm saying
it's i i'll tell you why i interview
people on the street all the time all
the time let me let me let me finish let
me finish i interview four times a week
i do a live show i interview i talk to
people all the time i ask girls would
you rather make three hundred thousand
dollars and work at an oil rig in alaska
or have a high status job where you make
no money most women pick no money
there's some exceptions there's some but
i'm telling you i ask women and men this
all the time more men say yes like men
are more willing to do hard jobs than
women and you can see that because the
hardest jobs the least like honored jobs
in society are all done by men um when
you talked about it's not sorry when you
talk about um equality the one trying to
say is the reason why i'm most women you
don't see most women in these kind of
fields is because they don't see a
representation so for example i'm i'm
black
but i want to go
for example i am black um i want to go
into for example um something that isn't
predominant doesn't have a lot of black
people is predominantly white
so obviously if i don't see
representation or people who look like
me i will be discouraged to pursue that
career because i would feel like i'm
going to be the odd one out straight
away i'm discouraged it's not all about
oh um and the reason why these quotes
exist is to encourage more people
encourage more women to come to these
areas so they can be the representatives
it's not a younger generation so so if
that's true if that's true why do it the
highest earning um
united states like group is indian
americans
in like from india that go so i'm saying
they're not represented in the media at
all but they outperform white people
black people they outperform everybody
in the u.s so if representation is the
standard like what evidence do you have
that representation increases in a field
because i can give you another example
nigerian americans they out they
outperform white americans
and that is representation when i see
nigerians being scientists guess what oh
i might actually give this a shot
because i'm seeing more black people
represented and being celebrated for
their creation if you were correct if
you were right then there wouldn't be
all of these examples where there's no
representation yet they come and
dominate in a field it's based off of we
all have to start from somewhere little
steps we all have to start from
somewhere to get there honestly question
do you do you really think like women
want to be in construction yes
yes i'm doing architecture i'm going to
go into construction management what are
you talking about
construction management but you're not
going to be the one on the video yes if
i want to if i owned the company and i
wanted to join in i can and
i think what was what were confusing is
when the roles with with little to no
position of power to rolls with and um
with a lot of power and obviously women
are fighting for
like anyone we are all fighting for
roles where we can make an influence and
an impact in the rest of the world in a
positive way and i'm not saying that
people who do not
who aren't in politics or in the
government oh you are because you keep
using the example of construction
workers on in a position of power or or
influence but what i'm saying is what
i'm trying to say is these quotas aren't
set in place to try and give women like
an upper hand it's set in place like she
said to encourage participation because
when you tell someone that they are
welcome they will be more likely to
enter a building but if you tell people
that sorry we do not accept your type
here they're not going to go forth and
go in and participate and i think that's
what these questions are trying to do
they're not trying to say oh you're a
woman let me hire you to fill a quote or
they're saying but we're saying we don't
have women in our company we want more
women to be in our company but we're not
going to pick you just because you're a
woman but we want you to feel like you
are capable of being here despite being
a woman so i think that is what these
quotas are doing they are trying to
encourage participation as opposed to
make people feel like they're paying
pick based on a specific demographic and
i think that's what they're trying to do
but at the end of the day i think it's
still sexist and i think it's offensive
like i think it's a yeah i think i think
it's offensive like why do i need a
quota to get a job like because i'm just
the type like i feel like i can do
anything and i like this youtube section
is very male dominant like every job
i've worked has always been male
dominated i don't need a quota to help
me get a job and like to meet like
that's offensive that you would think i
would need a quota when i'm the question
like why don't like to me it's like why
do i care if there's a man or a woman
doing it i'm going to do it anyway
it's not to help you get it it's it's to
help your encouragement is that is it
it's encourage you to i'm not a child
why do i need to be encouraged about
being a child but if you did not see a
single woman i wouldn't care well you
wouldn't you wouldn't care but you
you're still in you're still in a posi i
don't know how to explain that i didn't
know how to but you're you're
interpreting it and you're being
offended but i think the intention
behind what you're doing is not to
offend anyone but to try and encourage
participation i think that's the
intention but let's look at the results
and that's the thing is like it leads to
men being discriminated against because
they yes yes
because they're going to hire you you're
they're going to hire you based on your
sex and not your skills yeah i think
that's
like i said earlier like companies do
not hire based on your gender they hire
based on your skill and if you are a
woman that helps them fill a quota sure
and you get then you get a leg then you
get a leg up then you get a len you get
it then you get then you then you get a
leg up then you get because you were
women and you had the skills right
equals
but if it's equal if it's equal they're
going to go with the woman that's sexism
but nothing is equal and if it was equal
they then if it wasn't equal as well
then look at santander for example their
quota they don't even need a quota
because they have 50 50 ratio
roughly for mental female in fact i
think they have more female employees
than male employees in their company
but should we have a male quota
should we have male quotas for the
female dominated industries like i do
you want to put a milk like i don't know
what i don't know what you're trying i
don't understand what you're trying to
do my point is women only care about am
i
of course not so you're not a feminist
why aren't you
why because they don't they only care
about about equality when it doesn't
benefit them definitely feminism is the
fight for equal rights for both men and
women uh-huh then why don't we have male
quotas why don't they care about when
men get institutions
this is like this is this is what i'm
saying it's like created by men so guess
what the world we what the world we live
in is going to resolve around men likely
men have definitely historically men
recently just got the right to do many
things to work to vote like literally
that was 100 years ago not even it was
the only reason women most women didn't
want to vote if you like if you poll the
women at the time if you pull them if
you guys guys you keep interrupting me
if you pull the women at the time they
didn't want to vote like this is from
the horse's mouth so i'm saying so i'm
saying like if women didn't want to vote
because they they would have to be
drafted women never had to fight in wars
throughout all of history men tame the
world for us well definitely and i ask
you this question
obviously we're looking we're looking
we're looking at this from
men men and women but they have this the
same thing for race so are you now
saying that they should also remove
quotas for race they shouldn't try and
put these things in place to try and
encourage um disadvantaged ethnic
minorities into roles because if they do
then i'm just being picked because i'm
black so should they do the same thing
for race as well i just want to know
like do you stand like that because if
you're if you believe because the same
thing can be said for for for all the
questions and the things that they have
for raise do you believe that they
should also remove it because if they do
then you know did you know quotas
disproportionately affect the black
community in the us in a negative way
like when it comes to college entry no
i'm so i'm american and so like this is
my channel so i could kind of talk about
what i want like just yeah like
let's just and so i'm saying i'm saying
like yeah i think there's negative
consequences for quotas
all quotas yeah i don't remove the
programs that kind of help give provide
the people without this to provide
disadvantaged people with their skills i
didn't say that because that's the same
thing i didn't i didn't say that writers
aren't just quitters they're programmed
to help encourage people who aren't and
provide people with skills that they
don't have do you want my answer yeah
okay okay no i i don't believe in quotas
i don't believe in hiring i don't wait
let me finish i i am for
organizations that help communities i
that's time for if there's an
organization that encourages like things
like education helping with homework
like problems and it's actually doing
things to fix it no issue no issue my
issue is i don't think you should hire
someone based on sex or race i think
that is racist and sexist yeah true
i think what you don't think they should
have banned
is that weird i think if you're gonna
ban andrew tate then ban the women that
say men ain't [ __ ] and men are trash and
i think when i talk to women and they
don't feel anything when i say like
they're talking about men or [ __ ] men
ain't chat like hey to me it to me to me
says you don't want equality because if
you're going to say andrew tate's a
misogynist then ban the women that say
that men are trash do you know what
sorry oh i keep doing that i okay do you
know what i agree i agree to an extent
when you do it online and then you have
a mass following and a lot of people can
you can then inspire like a lot of a lot
of like um hate crime against women and
all of that stuff we are not inspiring
hate crime against men we were people
i'm saying everyone's entitled to their
opinion do you know who wendy williams
is yeah do you know that on national tv
that she laughed at a man getting his
chopped off for cheating she laughed and
said he deserved it and so it's like if
that happened to a woman if she got her
if she don't know but listen like not
not not really everyone laughed it was
on national tv she still uh she no way
let me let me she still she still had a
job and so i'm saying like like women
don't have the same energy for women
they they really don't and i and i can
see this because i ask women on the
street should these women be banned for
saying this for saying that it's always
no but the men should be banned and
that's why that's why when that's why
okay that's why we just finished that's
why when women say they're feminists and
they want equality i don't believe them
because the things you say aren't equal
one equality they want equity
but to me equity is all quality when it
benefits you it's not really equality
guess what the world will never benefit
women no matter how you try to yes you
guys are pretty girls okay you're pretty
girls you are treated better because
you're a pretty girl everyone with that
statement i think that's very i think
that's very
i think that's very close minded because
everyone has a struggle
you can be you could be pretty and still
struggle you can not be pretty
i'm not taking that away that you could
still struggle but but i'm not i'm not
taking i'm not i'm not i i'm not taking
away that you could still struggle but
i'm saying when you're a young man like
the world looks at you like you're
invisible one out of three men is either
a virgin or hasn't had sex in the past
year like men men lead in suicide they
lead in homelessness they like there's
issues that disproportionately affect
men that feminists don't talk about or
care about
men women women women get women get men
men get three times the same sentencing
for the same crime as a woman
three three times the same like that's
crazy i think that's like more research
and understanding that still needs to be
done and obviously again we are you're
asking two random people off the street
questions i'm not in a position right
now where i can go ahead and make any
differences or there's different things
that i would have if i was in a position
of power that i probably would have
addressed differently but again like
i think have say that you're not a
feminist and being a woman yourself that
i i don't i mean i can respect where you
stand but i don't agree with that
because you because if you if it hadn't
been for feminist you wouldn't be here
today doing what you're doing and you
probably i might be a housewife i wish
i mean you you want that but not
everyone wants that i wouldn't have
wanted that so for you to be able to
stand here today and do what you do i
think you should still give some
appreciation to the feminists and the
women who fought for our rights and the
women who still are because despite
because despite all the things you say
that we women have there's still a lot
we don't have and that's why all the
things we say that men what what rights
don't we have pardon what rights don't
we have see i won't i don't i don't have
a law book i wouldn't be able to stand
here and give it to you all but i can
tell you that
i've still been discriminated against
one for being a woman one for being
black and one for being a black woman so
it's not it's not that i don't what i
don't experience the privilege that
you're saying that women have maybe you
do but i don't i don't see what what
privilege do i i think privilege is
invisible to those who have it and it's
invisible
so is it is it a privilege for me to be
called on the street is that a privilege
is it a privilege for me to be told i
can't do this and be mocked up because
i'm a woman is that a privilege because
if that's a privilege i i didn't say so
if that's true why why is there women's
empowerment but there's not men's
empowerment because why do you need to
empower someone who's already in power
why do i need to tell donald trump you
can do it when he's already done that's
a very
different people majority the majority
the majority of men aren't in power
that's a very small percentage of men
how many female prime ministers have we
had you're the queen don't you i don't
know the government the queen is the
queen from birthright who how many
female prime ministers you got the queen
how many females how many how many oh
wait you're american how many female
presidents have you had
how many female presidents have here's
here's the thing that's a really big
list i know i know i know this is my my
interview you don't get to come in here
and tell me how i get to answer that's
rude so i'm saying i'm saying
the reason there has been zero
presidents is because most women don't
want to do that and the reason and
throughout history let me let me let me
let me finish let me finish let me let
me let me finish let me because it came
with a lot of responsibility like how
many presidents were assassinated
like people in positions of power it was
throughout history it was a hard place
to be because people would like you you
had a target on your back
and so that's the thing like you think
about the freedom but you don't think of
the responsibility that comes with it so
um who was her name was it hillary
clinton
she didn't want to be president because
she didn't want to get killed she was
trash
regardless of the regardless of the
political standing the point that i'm
trying to make is you're saying you're
saying that um you know there's no male
empowerment but again
if for your country you're from the us
you've never had a female pres you have
never had a female president what do you
tell a young girl who says i want to be
president despite all the difficulties
that they may be that's good
i would say i would say do it there's
nothing there's i would say i would say
i would say let me finish i would say
there is nothing stopping you go do it
if she wants to go do it go do it you're
empowering her so why are you white so
so why do you feel why do you feel
that's needed why do you need to tell
her that she could go do it go ahead i
would tell a guy if he wants to be
president go do it i would i'm i'm for
equality real equality now be completely
completely honest with yourself who do
you think would be more likely to get it
regardless of their political standing
or ideologies i think i and you're gonna
try to interrupt me here so you're gonna
let me finish this sentence i think the
man would but it's only because he would
want to i think most women i think most
women at a certain age they have a hard
time retaining women because they want
and choose to have a children and a
family so so so i would if i had two
guests i would guess the man would be
more likely to actually do it like for
example i i know people that hire at
high-end law firms and after 35 women
you can't pay them to stay because they
say [ __ ] this [ __ ] a career none of this
matters i want to go start a family and
i i think that's something innate in
women that you can't get rid of no
matter how much feminism tries to say we
don't have that like most women want to
be mothers
so in other words you agree with the
disparity between the genders because
women are innate mothers and things like
that so in other words okay you believe
the the man would do it more would most
likely do it because what if the woman
believes strongly that they can do it
what if they get to that age and says i
don't want to have kids i don't want a
family and i can do it so again you you
you've kind of gone ahead and done what
most political male leaders do and all
these like you you you're projecting
your own
you're protecting your own loki
misogynistic ideas as well so i i don't
think it's misogynistic to say women
should do what they want to do there are
no laws stopping you you can do whatever
you want you can do whatever you want to
do i think i i think that if women want
to do something they can do it but
in two groups you're never going to have
it 50 50. well you don't think we should
fight for it we shouldn't fight for 50
50. only if they want it to be
but women but like that's the thing like
you only care about 50 50 when it
doesn't benefit you you don't care about
men doing hard jobs like men are more
likely to die in the workplace
but you don't care about that all you
care is about is the positions of power
like all you look at is the and it's
true because i'm telling you based on
what you've said that what sorry no i
can't repeat the point because i'm no no
can you please repent i feel you i feel
pudding cause you please repeat the
point she wants to know what you just
said so what's the point
i'm saying that you don't care when
equality doesn't benefit you so i'm
saying i'm saying i'm saying like manic
the majority of workplace deaths like
men do harder jobs and so the only
positions you're talking about is these
small positions of power that's at
presidents like you don't talk about any
of the hard jobs and that's what i'm
saying when you make things like that
equal or representative of everyone it
can reflect down the chain if our
leaders did not lead a given example
then it wouldn't be reflected or seen
lower down if our parents did not give
us a good example of how to live life
then the kids wouldn't have that so you
can't go to somewhere starting you can't
you can't expect 50 that's an excuse
that's an excuse like honestly yeah yeah
because i i'm telling you i'm telling
you that's what i'm saying like that's
an excuse honestly because i i've been
in male dominated fields my whole life
it doesn't stop me i don't give a [ __ ]
of who i see up there and like and i'm
saying i'm saying but this is like a
victim mentality like oh poor me i don't
poor me i don't see women doing a job
like who cares
go do it
there's nothing stopping you go do it go
do it
if you want to be president go do it and
that's that's what i'm saying
so we should go and you're so you're
encouraging us to do it but you don't
want to
no no i'm saying if you want to do it go
do it you're encouraging us to do it but
then you're also against us being
encouraged to do it it doesn't make
sense against quotas i'm against legal
policies i'm against
i'm against i'm against no no i'm
against legal policies that say you must
hire someone based on based on you got
to let me i based on race or or gender i
think that's sexist and racist
i i am i am for people doing what they
want to do yeah well guess what the
world we live in is not fair okay
um for example as i said i want to be an
architect the field was predominantly
filled with mail so it's my field men
my field is done i understand men so
guess what without as what my friend
said without having feminists around
without pushing the gender that women
should be alive false false false
without women pushing i let you speak
let me speak
without women like you
pushing the agenda that women should
have the space and should have the the
the
to be comfortable to access to any field
without having that i wouldn't be here i
wouldn't even be able to come to school
here let's be real so you saying i would
i would be in the same place without
feminism
i would be in the same place
well guess what
without these quotas
without the especially ever since the
black lives matter movement happened
these questions have been popping up
especially to support black people and
black women
sometimes it's it's not just to
encourage 50 50 it's to allow people to
now see the abilities behind the people
who they've been shutting out because
when you've shut out a group of people
or you've not allowed them to succeed
and no women shut out when we have
women's empowerment but we don't have
men's empowerment pardon how are women
shut out if we have women's empowerment
we're not we're not just in one minute
this is recent it's not it's been it's
been it's incorrect it's been here since
the 60s yes and that is recent time
compared to hundreds of years of men
that has nothing to do but but like i
i'm 25. like what is it that's been uh
as far as i've been alive why am i
complaining about something that
happened before i was even born
all i can say
is i i appreciate you standing here i've
been willing to ask questions and share
your opinion and to try and like
educate me but i think you also don't
i'm being receptive of your ideas i
think you should be a bit more
respectful receptive of mine
because of course you you've definitely
and i hate saying this to people but i
have to say it to you you've lived the
privileged life
so have
during the play
you've been you've lived a more
privileged life than i have true
probably and i went i won't say because
i don't know your life experiences yeah
and you don't know mine
but what i can say is that if we both
walked into a store right now
you wouldn't be followed around i would
and i have been and if we both applied
to a job right now you would get it and
i wouldn't and unless maybe they had a
quota you don't know
and and was to do the same thing you
would get the job and you wouldn't and
if i was that's not true that's not true
that's not true that's not true that is
not true that is not true that is not
that it's not i look it look at look at
look at it look at look at look at look
at that that's not true because i i
again again they're telling you're
that's not it's not true because i have
applied two jobs that are male dominated
i've gotten all of them
excuses
right
right right right right
we've been going back and forth for a
while i just think i think we're good
okay
[Music]
would you date a guy that has excessive
credit card debt
i would
i would teach him
how to come out of it if he's nice and
loyal a guy won you struggle paycheck to
paycheck you barely get by but he's
faithful he's never cheating never
leaving option two all your bills are
paid you can go on vacation whenever you
want you live a luxurious lifestyle but
he may step out from side to side you're
the main chick but he here and there
here and there he might he might step
out you get all your bills are paid you
don't have to work if you don't want i'm
going with option a
action a why
would grind and do that together we'll
get there in the end
yeah yeah yeah yeah no no he he makes
this forever he makes this forever
there's no building him up forever and
you said i can't pick neva
well i think i still have to go for
option a i can't take the risk of option
b i've done that already we're not doing
that again
would you what would you guys rather
date okay or marry all right you have to
pick one of the two so no don't give me
any i'd pick neither you gotta pick one
a [ __ ] i mean a girl sorry we're
with with 50 bodies she slept with 50
people or
she has 50 000 in credit card debt that
you have to help pay off girl one girl
one she's got 50 bodies she's slept with
50 men you're 51
or or
option two she's got 50 000 in credit
card debt that you have to help pay off
now you have to pay off actually i think
i'd go with
option one if she's got
uh had 51 men i'll go with that
i'll go with option number one because
the reason being
i'll have to know who are the buddies
is it better this is the one with
straggle dagger kind of guys loser guys
then that's a bit of a problem they
actually got 50 bodies of saying jeff
bezos
is a bit different
if she's got 50 boys the elon musk yeah
about 50 bucks of strangled daggles guys
who are not worth anything i may have to
go with the fifty dollars one so it's
better it's better if she was [ __ ]
rich guys then but like if she was
picking some some rich guys i'll let it
go and she was [ __ ] some mom
you go on trips whenever you want you
can go out to dinner whenever you want
whatever you want to do but here and
there
he make a hoe like occasionally no no
one you're the only one he loves yeah
but it's just a side chick which one you
picking i would actually go for the guy
too because i don't want to be doing 50
50 and i don't
out of sight out of mind if i don't know
about it cool but what you don't know
doesn't hurt you see no see no evil
yeah same but not for the same reason
just because like i rather not struggle
right now when i'm older maybe but now
you get to pick between a girl she has
50 bodies she's slept with 50 people or
she has 50 000 worth of credit card debt
you have to help pay off they get all
worth 50. um yeah i'm not going to pay
for this 50 bodies 15 buddies 50 50 5
00. i mean i don't know 151 though
you're 51.
it's fine it's fine i'll just go for the
51. 50 000 pounds
for you
who cares 50 bodies who cares can't lie
you get to pick between a guy
you're struggling paycheck to paycheck
forever
so it's 50 50. he's not taking you out
to dinner he's buying you [ __ ] like it's
like you know maybe maybe a small gift
maybe some socks at christmas but he's
faithful he's never cheating never
leaving option two rich guy he takes
care of all of your bills 100 paid for
you get to go on trips whenever you want
you get to go to dinner whenever you
want but here and there he might [ __ ]
another girl he's not you're the only
one he loves though
number one
why i've been in a relationship i'm
still with my boyfriend now well we've
had no money shut up ben we've had no
money between us but we've been happy
and that's that's all i need happiness
and security
you're struggling paycheck to paycheck
you everything's 50 50. but he's loyal
he's never gonna cheat
guy too
takes care of all of your bills you're
set for a lifetime but he cheats now and
then
first one of course why
because he's loyal one girl has 50
bodies you're 51 though so yeah
girl 2 has 50 000
worth of credit card debt who are you
wiping fifty dollars
fifty thousand with that yeah why i'm
gonna work hard i'm gonna i'm gonna be
the a millionaire okay so i can pay your
debt pay it off yeah i pay it off i'm a
man i'm a man you can't be unfucked like
that
yeah you can't you can't undo that you
can't no no why not why not no i'm
saying with the the bodies like the 50
bodies yeah you can't you can't that's
it's too much bodies it's too much cut
there's so much work i think 10 is the
maximum it's the maximum that's a common
number i get around here yeah what about
11. can she get by 11 12. 11
okay eleven can you can can but twelve
twelve it's too much it's too much
so it has to be under on the elephant
eleven so really the number is 11.
it's important
what about 12 like 12 is right there
okay 12 maybe
maybe i'm gonna think i'm gonna take for
24 hours so then you might as well do
13. no no no no no no no right now
church is too much you get to pick one
of two guys option one you're splitting
everything 50 50. for life he's not
going to get he's not going to make more
money in the future this is forever 50
50. you can't really go on vacation
can't really go on trips all the money
goes towards the kids but he's faithful
he's never gonna cheat on you okay
option two he pays every bill you get
vacation whenever you want you can buy
clothes whenever you want you get a
credit card 10k a month plus whenever
but he might he might [ __ ] a hoe here
and there just on the side he only loves
you what you picking number one why
because i don't mind splitting the bills
50 50. because if he's going to be loyal
to me that means more to me do you think
it's bad for relationships when it's
based off of money not necessarily
everyone's different so it's whatever
floats your boat but for me personally
definitely option one what would you
guys rate yourselves one to ten eight
why confidence looks uh definitely an
eight one to ten today ten some days it
depends today ten definitely my
complexion is unique can't lie seven
seven there's always room four
okay okay now i'm going for eight then
eight i'll say
because if you're 10 there's no room for
improvement it means you're perfect
exactly i'm amazing so 10. um eight and
a half why and a half you're a [ __ ]
11 i'm i'm on the journey
that if you're saying tan you're saying
you're perfect because yeah because i
went through a journey to love myself
and i know i'm a good person
and i can even if i didn't have to
settle for someone i know i'm gonna have
a great life even by myself so i know
i'm a 10. is there no room for
improvement though one because 10 is
perfect maybe but i'm going to set
myself a high standard and then if i
want to reach another level i'll reach
another level like you're a 10 you're
trying to get to be 12. exactly exactly
exactly would you guys rate yourselves
one to ten ourselves
a very strong six and a half seven a
strong eight eight okay
eight
twelve always back myself so i have a
question for you if you're ten if you're
twelve does that mean you're perfect no
one's perfect so when i ask people but
i'm close
so what did you say if you're saying 12
that means there's no room for
improvement there's always room for
improvement but i'm always going to back
myself 100 so it's more of like a
confidence thing yeah i'm going to back
myself always come on what is a guy that
you would be settling for i think makes
me laugh
and it's respectful i i bite my mp so
i'm good with that
got my money have you ever heard the
term the bare minimum like accepting the
bare minimum yeah yeah they did
yeah yeah
what is the bare minimum that you should
accept from a man and a woman uh respect
christmas
christmas breast yeah the bare minimum
of accepting the bare minimum
loyalty
honesty
respect first of all is that it cooking
cleaning anything else i mean
who cares i don't really care can't lie
as long as you respect me i would say
time
love and patience they are all the bare
minimum
if you can't give me that then
that's part of respect though that it's
about respect yeah it is yeah so if you
can't do that then there's no there's no
grounds for a relationship what is the
bare minimum for a man what is it
exactly what to do you know like what
what is what should a man require from a
woman what do you think is the bare
minimum for them um
all they deserve
is
nothing
you don't think like if you had a
brother you don't think he should have
like standards for a girl yeah he should
have standards
yeah if he if he has styles for himself
that will reflect on what he is doing
what do you guys think the bare minimum
is that men should accept from women
a hairy funny
respect respect
what is your ideal partner he needs to
make me happy have ambitions
um goals in life and that he makes me
grow and now pushes me back what do you
offer your ideal partner um
empathy
um loyalty
yeah also like being honest and fair do
you cook do you clean um yeah
but not i like the if a guy cleans as
well
about accepting the bare minimum the
bare minimum for acceptance you at least
have to have a job right i think so at
least ambition ambition at least
yeah well let's have a shot be
passionate about something even if you
if you don't have a job be passionate
about something you're trying to get
better in yeah yeah so if you're writing
a book but you're not quite there you're
you know you're
passionate about writing that book you
know you might not be working as a
nine-to-five job but you know i'm going
to get this book out i'm going to be
here by i want you to be passionate
about something do you think even in
same-sex relationships there's a
masculine and a feminine for sure
well that's a funny question like
because i in terms of masculine and
feminine
i think sometimes i'm quite masculine in
terms of like in our in my relationship
i'm the main breadwinner i like to dress
quite androgynously sometimes
and yeah so like yeah i don't know if
that's basically i don't know if that
makes my partner less masculine but
those qualities i suppose are more
masculine type but yeah i'm the main
breadwinner for sure would you say like
i've always noticed when women are more
masculine which i don't sense like crazy
masculine energy from you like like
because some girls when i talk to
they're like they're
i don't get like crazy masculine energy
i just met you so i don't know maybe but
would you say that the women that are
more masculine tend to date guys that
are more feminine i don't think so i
think it's just um
i think my female friend kirsten yeah
she she's very female but she's quite
she can be the top yeah she can be the
dominant one in the relationship but the
guys she's been with are still very
manly have you ever heard the term of
the bare minimum like accepting the bare
minimum from a man yeah what is the bare
minimum the minimum for me yes love
loyalty respect what is the bare minimum
respect morals principles
and that's it
we wish we wish kate we wish that was a
better thing
respect
respect man
respect
um accountability is one of them as well
for me the bare minimum is when no no
effort at all is made like
when you get with someone i think bare
minimum is like
they need to make you want to feel like
you want to be of them right
yeah and they means when they not do
that they don't do that
yeah like if they're doing the bare
minimum they ain't treating you right
they should be going over and above
tonight a little bit like
you want to be wanted and if you're not
wanted then do you feel like there's a
bare minimum for men as well that they
should be demanding of course right it
works both ways like i feel like men
have bare minimum when they sleep with
girls
do you know what i mean but like girls
they have a bit more standard
what are your standards
[Music]
you have to make a certain amount of
money no no no no no no no
she be overweight does she have to be in
shape then hey i don't like i don't mind
a little tommy you know that you get me
i don't discriminate discriminate
discriminate for those of you i would be
like too pale right it would be yeah no
no no no no you say caribbean thing
caribbean goes
as long as
who has higher standards men are women
women women
yeah
women
we always talk about how women should be
treated like queens why don't we ever
talk about how men should be treated
like kings
i agree 100 percent dude that should be
true like kings are lying
[ __ ] you see women yeah women listen we
love women at the end of the day but at
the end of the day it's just the
standards are too hard to put pressure
on men alive i don't feel pressure on it
but listen as long as she's an island
girl she's on our grind we can move what
is your ideal partner i don't even know
just someone that treats you right and
that doesn't look elsewhere so do you
know what i mean i mean i'm not gonna
lie they're gonna if you want them to be
your partner they're gonna have your
kids so they're like
don't stop me slap me
no i don't know like they just can't be
like they've got to be taller than me
how cool is that i don't know i'll leave
here
is there a certain amount of money he
has to make no
money but at the end i think it doesn't
matter how much money they make at the
time but they've got to have drive
because
in life
if you don't have any money between you
works both ways then you're going to
struggle in life but they don't have to
have money to stop but they've got to
have ambition to change it so if you
dated a guy with no money he has to be
working on it that's fair
yeah
for me i wouldn't get with a guy who had
no money
yeah i mean they've got to have some
money to be able to make but
it doesn't matter what they're spending
on me do you know what i mean have you
heard of women say they've accepted the
bare minimum no you've never heard that
term you're like like the bare minimum i
accepted the bare minimum yeah yeah yeah
what what is the bare minimum the bare
minimum is i've got taken on a date and
i get treated nicely that's the bare
minimum that's the bare minimum yes
messaging me
you're really trying to be special take
me on a date you'll plan it you'll pick
me up everything cameras what do you
feel like it's the bare minimum you
should offer to a man contacting them
responding okay yeah do you think it's
fair for him to expect you to like cook
for him and clean if he's paying for you
no if
do you feel like it should be 50 50 when
it comes to paying for dates that should
be 50 realistically a man should be
doing all of that because you're
courting me you want me i want you but
you want me more than i want you so what
do men get out of the deal because
that's what i've i've heard is um my
presence like i'm there that's it anyone
could be there i know but for a man that
actually wants you
i'm there i'm giving you my time yeah
that's it why isn't he giving you his
time yes but men are men men are fast
i'm sorry sorry man
i'm so sorry what is the bare minimum
for men and for women exactly nothing
bare minimum for a girl i don't know a
bad minute for a girl
what would you what's the bare minimum
you would accept from a woman big racks
exactly big whaps
men with dirty fingernails the bare
minimum except from a girl a girl that
is
caring that's the bare minimum you gotta
be caring as a female that's about it
the rest i don't really care about a guy
needs to see me once a week at least
that's the bare minimum you need to clip
your
nails question what is the bare minimum
men should expect from women so you have
a brother a son what is the bare minimum
we should bring to a guy be in there
that's it you don't think that's like
nothing that's nothing bad minimum you
said minimum minimum means low just
being there that's bare minimum
and nothing bring cash god could just be
there yeah i don't need to bring cash
because unfortunately the patriarchy set
it up so that i don't actually have to
bring money as a woman you want me to
cook i can cook a little small one so
you think you've got mac and cheese
maybe a little bit of salt a little bit
of pepperonis
taste all right listen do you see the
color on my skin of course i can
determine i can do a bit more than that
that's a lot more than bare minimum so i
always hear women say
i accepted the bare minimum right
yeah so so i'm asking what what is it
what is the bare minimum standards which
are
in what context though like what is the
like generally yeah relationships like
what is the bare minimum care of you
spending time with you paying for the
meal
texting every day vacation being honest
keeping it real
paying for you buying your gift i feel
like that's bad minimum yeah what is the
bare minimum that men should that we
should bring to the table for a man care
love respect
just matching their energy if they're
doing good for us i feel like we should
do good for them
match the end if they're not matching
energy then they gotta go
if a man if a man pays your bills and is
paying for dates and everything
should totally break should should he
expect you to cook and clean no no no
for something if if they treat me right
and do everything for me i'm gonna
return that energy so we're eating
you're paying for them i'm not doing
more than you in order to do more than
me you know so then in the name of
equality like would it wouldn't you do
that back for him like
anything he does to me i'll do that for
him
so you would pay for dates 50 50. yes
no no no no
not the first day but i'll treat him if
he treats me i'll treat him he treats me
i'll treat him from time to time or like
50 of the time time to time i'll
surprise him i'll shoot my mom so that's
not matching energy though because he's
still doing more than you're doing for
him
so i believe you must forget the
deadline
but not in the beginning oh i'll match
50 50. but in the beginning i feel like
he has to pay for the birthday
definitely what do you guys think of
andrew tate come on it's just it's
purposely it's purposely saying the [ __ ]
that people they get they will get upset
people we we are a generation where
people give attention to things they get
upset think negative things like most of
the times we don't really care about the
positive things that happens in front of
our eyes we're just looking for the
negatives so that's what he's doing just
to be viral and get money whatever but i
think he's saying [ __ ] at the same
time saying things that makes they make
sense but it's just playing with the
with the crowd can't lie i think anyone
who supports him outside of his
misogynistic view so people can say he's
he speaks good about financial
situations but anyone who thinks that is
not an ally for women because he speaks
so he's so detrimental to women so don't
give him the time of day and i think
guys that listen to him are respected as
well
i'm headed out listen i'ma head out
because listen yeah i don't even know
and i've never watched that man's video
in my life it's all over tick tock all
of my tick tock for you page i have
never watched a video but i've seen
everywhere i'm guessing he's not the
best in terms of the opinion of women so
do you think he's misogynistic
from what i gather yeah i didn't say it
but they said it and i don't disagree
with that person
have you heard of andrew tate i think
andrew tray i like him i like him
because he's controversial yeah he's
controversial i like controversial man
you know what is his own opinion but i
agree 80 percent
thinks
uh what he say especially about the
government and some some things about
men
men has to provide for the women yeah
especially 50 you got to pay off that
debt
you got to pay off that day
okay but andrew chad you know yeah he's
a millionaire yeah right
there's a lot of money so do you agree
that he should have been banned on all
social media platforms yeah he has money
so he doesn't need he doesn't need
social media i i i don't know i don't
really care i can't lie yeah no no
definitely it's good that's been taken
away from social media but a lot of
other people can should be taken away
from social media at the same time i
don't think banning him made much of a
difference because it wasn't his own
platforms that were like
yeah like
promoting it yeah it was other platforms
so yeah i don't think badly made that
much of a difference why do they ban him
but the women that say men ain't [ __ ]
and men are trash get to say that freely
why is that
no because it's a personal view on men
as a whole people can be feminist people
can have their views on men women
just because they've said one line men
are trash that doesn't mean they need to
be off social media andrew tate has
slandered women he has assaulted women
and he is just a general misogynist and
extremist so he shouldn't be allowed on
these platforms
i think
we live in a world where
it ain't fair and unfortunately it ain't
fair yes you're honest yeah it ain't
fair you know what i mean this double
sign is for women double standards for
men yeah unfortunately that's just how
the cookie crumbles
to be honest because women rule
i don't think that's a good enough
answer but honestly maybe you're being
honest yeah
women have time to drag men on social
media but men don't have time like that
to sit down and start to drag women do
you get why me women aren't working so
like we're we're we're staying now
and say because we're talking about like
assault that like like cardi b shouldn't
be given a platform because she's
admitted to acting a man i don't know
anything about her i mean
what like i said what matters is what
what do we give attention to these
people are famous just because we give
attention of the fact that they're
extremists and they say [ __ ] all the
time only the only reason i'm asking is
i just want to see if people actually
want equality dude i'm saying so like
i mean i think if we're going to take
him down for that we should take the
women down let's say men ain't [ __ ] yeah
like i think that's sexist like like
yeah
but it's it's weird because the the
companies i don't know any woman that is
on the same level as andrew tate i i can
think of a couple like i i
don't know though if you found that like
party like cardi b cardi b like like
openly admitted she used to drug men and
rob them okay and so i'm like if a man
was drugging women and robbing them and
said that on online he would be taken
off immediately but like but like for
some reason women get away with it yeah
i i agree i think everyone should be
treated equal however andrew tay has got
a lot more publicity
andrew tate before he got the big ban uh
i'll say he's a good guy he definitely
needs to improve on how he delivers and
he's approached on certain people
because i know i understand like he
doesn't care at some point but the way
this time goes there's a way of saying
things and the way of delivering words
that can be really helpful and then
people won't be so much discouraged on
how he acknowledged certain things why
do you think they banned him off of
social media but they don't ban the
women that say men are trash and men
ain't [ __ ] because there's someone in
control and they know i don't know who's
had a hierarchy that's controlling the
media but they know what they're doing
in it and i'll say i think it's all
about who's in control so i'll say we
live it's the time that we live in the
time that we live in and basically that
shows yeah yeah certain things are okay
on some things or not so
they're not okay what he says like
things he say and now all the things but
it's just the time that we live in
that's why i believe so what do you guys
think of andrew tate
i hear my
[Music]
what happened to the other guy
do you know who kevin r samuels is
kevin samuels he died [ __ ] a
prostitute
that's all i'm gonna say that's what we
think about youtube why do they ban
andrew tate but they don't ban the women
that say men ain't [ __ ] and men are
trash women can say a lot of things of
men because
right now this is a it's a woman's world
yes back in the days what's a man's work
right now it's a woman's work yeah so
cardi b got to be said i forget where i
forget what uh cardi b said but she said
something about uh she back in the day
she uh man she robber man she can she
she can say uh that things but if
entertain and tate uh said
uh
the man has to provide for the woman and
the woman has to be
in their home to cook to clean or
something about that
why why is that the problem
why i i don't think it is okay do you
like anything yeah
okay
so andrew
i love you on the date you know we're
from holland we support you you know
shut up we are
great from cape verde cape verde island
west africa and we love you undertake
free undertale you know and you take we
love you and i also love poa
think of andrew tate i i'm [ __ ] off
this is fantastic
oh andrew j ah no comment
he's a disgrace to the male species do
you think it's good he got banned 100
um
he's a misogynistic pig and i'm very
happy that he's not around anything do
you guys believe in equality
not total equality men and women are
made different but we just strive for
economically
the women that go on tick-tock and send
men ain't [ __ ] and men are trash should
they be banned too
metatron
you think they should be banned too i
think there are some people who are good
and some who are bad men and women
doesn't matter no men are trash no women
are trash we're all just people men and
women you know we're
we're we're equal but we're all
different as well do you know what i
and that's the mean line what do you
guys think of andrew tate you are a king
they're trying to slap they're trying to
cut you down because you're a king
you're a king
listen i'll take all the slender you're
a king keep doing your thing don't let
instagram knock you off bro keep doing
it find another platform
listen
okay so question why why do they ban
andrew tate but they don't ban the women
that say men ain't [ __ ] and men are
trash because they're terrified they're
terrified they're terrified they're
allowed to hear the truth why are men
shamed every time they have a standard
like if they don't want to date a fat
chick or a girl that's been ran through
why are they shamed for that i don't
know i never understood that i don't
know i have no idea okay i have no idea
what's up
i don't know but
what do you guys think of andrew tate i
love yeah i love him we love him
hilarious
he's actually funny he says a lot of
real facts he says something that's
crazy i'm not gonna lie even though he
just mad he chats
that in this generation that's what men
want so as much as we want to be like oh
you can't do that men are going to do it
and men are in power so therefore that's
how life runs she's getting deep right
now why why don't they ban why don't
they ban the women that say men are
trash and men ain't [ __ ] on social media
no because many [ __ ] i'll be honest men
and [ __ ] well what did you say that's
sexist
probably well so like
as much as i say minnie [ __ ] woman ain't
[ __ ] evil not elimination what do you
think of andrew tate [ __ ] disgusting
guy
yeah yeah
absolutely misogynistic disrespects
women he's a sexual assault or happy
abuser one of them yeah what do you
think if if we're banning andrew tate
because he's a misogynist should we ban
the women that say men ain't [ __ ] and
men are trash because wouldn't you say
that's sexist too unfortunately the way
the world works right now the women
don't actually have the power by saying
that men ain't [ __ ] the the men that
reign the patriarchy have a lot more
power you see how the little kids follow
andrew take by right and say follow
whatever he wants to say that doesn't
really matter to me the fact that he ran
away from the law i meant to romania to
be free from the charges if you face the
charges in subway you want to say fine
don't you think you're innocent until
proven guilty fine fine but then don't
be talking up and down up in the
internet until you are proven guilty
because by that logic shouldn't we get
rid of cardi b's platform because she
know i agree
listen i'm all here for equality what do
you guys think of andrew taylor
[Music]
do you guys agree with him getting
banned yeah
we've just
learned together obviously our opinion
is the internet is a free play freedom
of speech i feel like yeah i agree we
don't agree with it doesn't mean you
can't justify everyone deserves freedom
of speech
so you would disagree with him getting
banned then for spreading freedom of
speech
just because
i mean everyone should have a freedom of
speech but i don't agree with him okay
so but you guys do believe in equality
right like you do believe men and women
should be equal so in the name of
equality should we ban the women that
say men ain't [ __ ] and men are trashed
because that's sexist
women have more of a reason to say that
their stats for [ __ ] is higher so a
lot of people think that but that's not
necessarily true if you look at abusive
relationships actually men are abused in
in one-sided abusive relationship
meaning that one's hitting the other and
they're not hitting back men are abused
by women more than women are abused by
men so does that but i'm saying i'm
saying that that's like a stat right and
so by that logic like men could go
around saying well women ate children
women are trashed
right they do
like in the name of equality shouldn't
we want that to be equal we're like
women can't just say sexist things about
men men say
our world is actually built by men yeah
they made the system you get two choices
of a man man one you split everything 50
50. he doesn't make a lot of money but
he loves you
and he's never going to cheat never
going to leave guy 2 he cheats on you
but he pays all the bills and you're
taking care of her life
number one
number one number one number one because
i wouldn't feel comfortable for anyone
paying for my stuff i feel like
if we
i appreciate the person more than i
appreciate the money 100 you have two
women okay and woman one has slept with
50 men you're 51 you're 51 though so
like you got in there
a woman too has fifty thousand dollars
worth of credit card debt you have to
pay off who are you picking
um woman too
a dad woman too why i think i can look
with money money money comes in gold so
i can deal with money i think like for
women's have that many men it's kind of
for general for generally i'm speaking
for most men i can't speak for everyone
including myself it's kind of a bit of a
put off you know what i mean hey what
i'm hearing each each body is like a
thousand bucks in debt and you'd rather
take thousand bucks in debt over each
body and has this woman with 50 000
pounds in debt she hasn't got a high
body count
yeah yeah let's say let's say
all today when i ask how many bodies is
too many 10 is like the magic let's say
below 10. let's say below 10. oh then i
can deal with that you can deal with
that would you like a girl you don't
have to pick one 50 bodies or 50 000 in
credit card debt the debt i don't want
no bodies
crazy a rich man who takes care of you
but cheats are a loyal man who's broke
loyal broke man i don't care a rich man
that cheats because ignorance is bliss
hi
yeah well yes basically i used to just
live anyhow i didn't believe in god
wasn't looking for god but god came to
me by the holy spirit and god asked me
if i believe in the father son and holy
spirit i replied yes so do you guys feel
like the church has driven men out of it
in the last like 50 years no i don't
think the church has driven men out of
the church i think men are not um
standing or taking up their
responsibility to be in the church to be
servants of god because it's not just
going to church because really yes the
church are
a people the people not a building so
it's really about men
standing up for god and taking their
stand so i i feel like it starts with
the women though and i i think a lot of
times like this is just my experience
like the church drives men out because
they they encourage them to accept bad
deals from women so like for example
like you have a lot of girls that come
out at like 28 29 and now all of a
sudden they found god conveniently when
they need a husband and it's like the
church kind of encourages men to like
take that deal even though it's like a
bad one for men i i just by from talking
to a lot of men because we we have whole
shows on like christian dating like a
lot of them say like i went to church to
find a wife but there's no wives here
it's like a bunch of single mothers and
ran through hoes so like how do you
balance like on one hand you want people
in the church but like sometimes i think
letting everyone in dilutes like the
quality of the people
so i don't know how do you balance that
yeah i think and the church
has got a standard you know
understanding of the church is the word
of god
so
it's not everybody is gonna want to
conform to the standard of god
but nevertheless um god's standard is
always the best standard no they they
say that though like come on like let's
just let's just be real a lot of a lot
of the girls come into the church
and like it's like convenient because
they find god after they've slept with
the whole football team or they find god
after they have a kid with two different
baby daddies so it's like you walk into
the church like the men are looking for
wives and they all they have is these
old hoes that like found god and so it's
like if you let everyone in the church
it kind of dilutes the quality of the
people for me i think everyone is should
come into the church everyone is invited
i feel like we should kick people out no
no you have two kids two different
for me
for me everybody
is invited into the church yeah you
think if they're not living according to
principles we should like kick them no i
don't
you see jesus jesus says let the wheat
and the tears grow together
until the time of harvest then he will
root them out i went to italy right and
it was hot it was like 80 degrees and i
was in these shorts i walk in the church
the pastor gives get out
get out like because he's like you can't
come in here i felt i felt i felt like
home
i was like that's good because i feel
like there should be a standard for the
people that are in the church the bible
says a woman should dress modestly but
at the same time
it says judge not according to their
appearance but judge your righteous
judgment according to the word john 7
24. where i don't i don't have the
answer but it's like i could just tell
you because i i talk to men daily and
like the common theme is that like they
go to the church and there's just no
standard for the women anymore and
they're telling them it's their
responsibility to wife single mothers
when it's like you made that bed i feel
like you lie in it i was sent a video
which on youtube which i i made a reply
to and i was quite strong they got these
girls who looked about
19 20 21
and they were dancing at the front of
the church but they were in very short
skirts kicking their legs up and down
doing some assaults yeah yeah that's
what i'm saying it takes a bit when you
let everyone in and dress the way they
want like it takes away from the
credibility of the church because it's
like what why are we coming here if i'm
just going to see i think can i just can
i just finish off by saying i think i
think god doesn't look at the appearance
he looks at the heart no i don't doubt
people do change like i'm not i'm not
doubting that what i'm doubting is like
a lot of people do it what it's um they
they do it when they're like it's like
mad convenient and like it it doesn't
seem genuine when it's like you spent
the last years ten years like this is
for the women getting like dick down
and like now you have two kids from two
different dads and now you found god
what are your times running like it just
doesn't seem genuine i understand that
um but you know the problem is not um
them being in the church the problem i
think is that when they are in the
church how how are they taught how they
should live when some are taught they
don't care they don't care they're still
on instagram when we teach them the word
of god and how they should live and if
they continue living that way the bible
says now this
kick of eat no
wheat let the wheat and tears
grow together
if you let too many weeds in then
everyone's weeds no no
because if you
are goodbye rebecca you've slept with
the whole football team
no
if you are a wheat
then you have to keep
the standard
so
and your standard will show them that
how they they are living is not right so
they will either go themselves
or they will change or they'll trick a
guy into thinking that they change even
though they did it and the last 10 years
of their lifestyles they did it then the
dude like i see this all the time in the
church where like all the chastity
speakers that would come through i'm
gonna tell you my beef okay the chastity
speakers it would always be a girl that
was ran through and a dude who wiped her
up after she then ran through and it's
like
[Music]
it's like now you're telling all the
girls that you can get ran through and
still get a husband
no
no
again that's why we need discernment to
allow the spirit of god to lead us
and to
direct us to the wife or the husband
that he has the partner for us to see so
that's important to have that
relationship with god so you can be led
by god concerning a partner you know i
would i would counsel them
baby mama's back to the streets send
them back catch me on
www.goddesgreatministry.net
what is the bear what is the bare
minimum bare minimum and i'll take you
out man and i give a good cocky that's
the bare
minimum like a good cookie bro
i don't is that i don't i'm not from
what does that mean if you're not giving
them the lung
okay okay go back to school go back to
school
go back to school stop
yo yo i can't i can't with these kids i
can't
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible